I'm gonna go as Clara Barton she was the
founder of the American Red Cross and
she also did charitable work even when
women were just expected to be at the
home she went out and did what she
wanted to do I think that someone like
Rosa Parks a lot of people could stand
behind and it would be kind of a
crowd-pleaser across the board I think
that someone should be there like Rosa
Parks who did something really
monumental for our country
and nothing like celebrities well is the
best Hattie Stan
that helps organize other feminists to
get the vote going
and I just think she was a leader and an
inspiration to young women everywhere I
think the person that should be ominous
$10 bill to be Rosa Parks because it
shows how the actions of just one woman
can change
you think playing like a girl is easy
let me show you what it takes
playing like a girl is